[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono riccardo piccirillo e sono un
fotografo napoletano
quelle che vedete scorrere alle mie
spalle sono le fotografie che
normalmente realizzo
si tratta di ritratti musicali ma io
questa sera sono qui non per raccontarvi
di queste fotografie ma sono qui perché
vi voglio parlare di un progetto che
fino a questo istante fino a ora è
rimasto chiuso in un cassetto un
progetto che a cui tengo tantissimo e
questo il motivo perché è rimasto chiuso
ho fatto precisamente come faceva mia
nonna rita quando a natale le regalavamo
un pullover arrivavamo da nonna col
pacco io davamo non lo apriva avendo
cura di non rompere la carta
rigorosamente lo guardava diceva
bellissimo non lo indossava nemmeno si
commuoveva poi richiudeva il tutto
facendo un pacco ancora più preciso di
quello che con cui ci siamo presentati e
lo metteva in un cassetto
a distanza di anni andavamo da nonna
diciamo non ama quel pullover che ti
abbiamo regalato tre anni fa natale ma
non te lo abbiamo mai visto poco se non
ti piace perché non te lo sei mai messo
mano mi guardai faceva nonna è
bellissimo e che se me lo metto si
sciupa ecco io avevo paura di sciuparle
queste fotografie e per questo sono
rimaste chiuse in un cassetto ma lo sono
rimaste anche perché anno e lo vedremo
tra poco un contenuto politico naturale
e avevo paura che in qualche modo
fossero venissero strumentalizzate
poi sono foto che a cui tengo moltissimo
e che volevo presentarvi io volevo in
qualche modo essere partecipe mentre le
facevo vedere per accompagnarle perchè
credo che la motivazione che mi abbia
portato a fare queste fotografie sia
importante almeno quanto le fotografie
così stavano per diventare un libro con
dei testi stavano per diventare una
mostra con catalogo potevano diventare
potevano andare sul sito web
sarebbero potute divenire un articolo di
un giornale avrei potuto farle
partecipare ad un concorso no non me la
sono sentita
ho detto quando ho ricevuto l'invito a
venire qui stasera ho detto ecco la
l'occasione per indossare il pullover di
nonna questa sera posso raccontare di
questo progetto di queste foto
ma arriviamo c quando faccio le
fotografie musicali o un duplice
obiettivo il primo obiettivo è quello di
realizzare un ritratto iconico e il
secondo è che sia bello per retratto
iconico intendo un tipo di fotografia
che riesca a riassumere in una sola foto
la musica il musicista il tipo di
messaggio che vuole dare al pubblico
insomma lo voglio fare con un esempio
per renderlo più facile immaginate un
vinile di marilyn manson o dei metallica
quindi rock molto molto duro e
immaginate che in copertina riporti il
volto sorridente di albano sarebbe un
disastro e per al bano e per i metallica
e poi dicevo il secondo obiettivo è che
sia bello sì perché nel momento in cui
tutti gli elementi che compongono questo
tipo di ritratto sono in armonia tra di
loro
quindi la musica il messaggio la persona
il personaggio
il risultato sarà bello bellezza intesa
non chiaramente come bellezza fisica ma
come armonia
vi assicuro che nel momento in cui
riesce questa cosa arriva la massima
soddisfazione per il fotografo perché il
soggetto si sentirà naturalmente bello
dirà come sto bene in questa fotografia
per il fotografo questo è il massimo che
si possa ottenere in assoluto quel
giorno però mi son fermato mi sono
interrogato detto ma questa metodologia
cioè la bellezza il risultato dalla
bellezza applicata a qualcuno che non ha
più voglia di farci vedere nulla
qualcuno che sta in difficoltà a
qualcuno che ha un vago ricordo della
bellezza oppure la proprio abbandonato
riesco e qualche modo a farlo venire
fuori riesco a farlo sentire bello
questo soggetto l'opportunità si è
presentata due anni fa
sono stato invitato a fare fotografie
all'interno di un cast centro di
accoglienza straordinaria a monteforte
irpino in provincia di avellino
il centro di accoglienza straordinaria
il cas ospita migranti quindi ragazzi
arrivati con i barconi ragazzi e ragazzi
arrivati quei barconi dall'africa e che
quindi hanno un passato terribile hanno
terrore di parlare di quello che gli è
successo sono dovuti scendere a patti
con la dignità hanno messo via
l'orgoglio non si ricordano neanche più
che cos'è la bellezza e si trovano in un
momento che è un limbo si trovano in in
attesa di un futuro che non sanno
neanche quale è che non possono nemmeno
decidere detto secondo noi loro sono
perfetti per i miei ritratti posso
provare a vedere se li fotografo come i
musicisti come le mie rockstar che cosa
succede
per fare questo però avevo bisogno di un
pretesto e ho pensato mi serviva quello
che in sostanza è la musica per i
musicisti un elemento per creare
l'armonia tra il soggetto e quindi farlo
sentire bello quindi la bellezza sempre
come armonia ci ha ragionato ha detto
che cos'è che loro hanno che mi possono
mostrare che nessuno gli può togliere ci
ho ragionato e ho pensato ai sogni
bisogna anche noi li conserviamo le
abbiamo
nessuno ce li può toccare e anche per
loro nessuno li può toccare però come
fare a farglieli venire fuori mi serviva
il pretesto
così ho rivolto loro una domanda molto
semplice quando eri bambino che cosa
avresti voluto fare da grande ti posso
realizzare una fotografia mentre me lo
fai vedere questa questo sogno che avevi
in effetti pensavo a me io da bambino
volevo fare il chitarrista cioè oggi se
mi fate una fotografia con la chitarra
in mano mette così io non sono bello
sono bellissimi più sulle più grande
chitarrista al mondo non c'è dubbio
in quel ritratto quando per fare questa
domanda immaginate me che arrivò al
centro mi vedono arrivare io costruisco
un piccolo set rudimentale piccolo e
questo set resta in un angolo c'è una
barriera di diffidenza mi guardano e
dicono che vuole questo che sta facendo
a casa nostra
io sono riuscito a romperla grazie
all'aiuto di daniela mariangela e
michela che sono le ragazze che
aiutavano ad integrarsi gli ospiti del
centro
così l'oro che ha posto la domanda io
avrei potuto fare qualsiasi tipo di
fotografia all'interno del centro avrei
potuto raccontare nelle condizioni far
vedere che tipo di vita svolgono ma il
mio intento non era quello di smuovere
coscienze sul tema dell'immigrazione no
inventato se permettete un pizzico di
presunzione era superiore era regalare
bellezza questi ragazzi farli sentire
importanti farli sentire belli farli
sentire rockstar come di vento come
facevo con i miei musicisti
per fare questo volevo realizzare delle
fotografie più concettuali sì perché
oggi ci sono anche delle regole in
fotografia una di queste per esempio che
la fotografia il serie o il ritratto non
va più di moda quindi per esigenze di
una fotografia più moderna avrei dovuto
fare potuto fare dei ritratti
concettuali quindi ho detto va bene
magari io sogni li faccio accennati no
magari basta un gesto un'idea vediamo i
ragazzi come rispondono ma il primo
ragazzo che è arrivato è arrivato col
pallone sotto il braccio detto io
calciatore io calciatore egli sia
illuminato il bosco valore tratto così e
quindi è nata è diventata una corsa in
due giorni a recuperare gli attrezzi del
mestiere per farli sentire in armonia
con questi attrezzi e ha davanti non
avevo più ospiti di un centro lo chef
calciatori avevo tutte persone che erano
nel pieno del loro mestiere i sogni
erano diventati realtà anche solo per un
attimo il mio obiettivo era era riuscito
i ragazzi erano diventati belli anche
più belli dei musici io adesso vi faccio
vedere queste fotografie
premetto che sono sono fotografie che ho
fatto vedere prima che a voi questa sera
ad alcuni amici che stimo tantissimo e
che mi hanno mandato dei testi che
adesso leggerò ispirati dalle visione
delle fotografie ne leggerò solo alcuni
perché sono diversi però li posso
ringraziare tutti e mi sembra il minimo
quindi ringrazio erri de luca fabrizio
poggi sergio maglietta maldestro guy
davis luthi fosse
cos'è che il bolero sid
ringrazio raffaele bruno benedetta
palmieri filippo gatti e andrea melis
erri de luca che vuoi fare da grande
a questa petulante domanda rivolta ai
bambini avrei risposto banalmente lo
scrittore con la stessa in realtà di un
altro che direbbe l'astronauta
in questa galleria di fotogrammi in posa
la domanda è cosa vuoi fare da salvato
la propone riccardo piccirillo fotografo
in visita al centro di monteforte irpino
a 40 giovani ospiti di origine africana
tolgo di mezzo le parole profughi
immigrati richiedenti asilo ho imparato
sulla nave soccorso di medici senza
frontiere che salvati sono ospiti e
benvenuti a bordo ci sono navi pure in
terraferma dove smaltire le quarantenne
imposte dall'europa
premesse che sono stati salvati scippati
da gli affondamenti selezioni selvagge a
mare calmo con serietà e 40 partecipano
al gioco di rispondere nessuno di loro
desidera fare il salvatore sono stati
issati a bordo da canotti alla deriva
hanno saputo che il mare e deserto samia
mobile sudario nessuno vuole fare il
bagnino nemmeno lo scrittore hanno
desideri solidi e terrestri non sogni
non garbugli di immagini notturne hanno
aspirazioni di urne è stato di veglia di
coscienza
le realizzeranno usciranno dal limbo del
centro metà recinto e metà collegio i
viaggi attraversati diventeranno
lentamente storie trasmesse nipotini
la vita dei salvati e un'antologia di
cicatrici questa galleria di ritratti è
un punto di sutura sopra la ferita sulla
beata di due sponde del mediterraneo
sogna più forte di loro di andrea melis
che un poeta io sono razzista ma non
vedo arrivare bambini denutriti non vedo
arrivare vecchi non vedo arrivare donne
vedo arrivare baldi giovani ben nutriti
e palestrati vedo arrivare prostituzione
spaccio vendita di merce contraffatta
che ha intenzione di venire qui a vivere
nella legalità è il benvenuto
il resto se ne può tornare a casa è una
giovane donna che scrive questo su
facebook sono tante giovani donne che
scrivono e strillano questo a suon di
punti esclamativi
a conferma che certe cose è ovvio non si
vedono con gli occhi
bisogna avere un cuore per riuscire
vedere i bambini che sarebbero dovuti
essere questi baldi giovani le donne che
sarebbero dovute essere queste
prostitute i vecchi sereni che avrebbero
voluto diventare queste braccia forti
arruolate alla piccola criminalità al
piccolo malaffare in fuga dalle norme
criminalità ed enorme malaffare
per una volta combattiva come si deve
questa gente che dice di disprezzare
combatti la ad armi pari tu hai avuto il
sogno bene provo a sognare più forte di
loro che hanno sognato più forte del
male e se sognerei forte quanto loro
vedrà in abdallah un giocatore di basket
in abruzzo ma né un politico in album
batterista in appena un chirurgo in caro
una studentessa in mustafa un meccanico
in zona un avvocato in justice un
ingegnere navale e in tutti i loro
calciatori banchieri rapper uomini
d'affari chef agricoltori medici piloti
elettricisti professori insegnanti
infermieri pompieri dimmi cosa hanno di
tanto diverso da te a parte che loro
sanno dove l'italia e non hanno sognato
così forte da superare ogni male per
arrivare qui a farne la loro casa mentre
tu non hai idea neppure di trovare sulla
mappa la loro nigeria la loro guinea il
loro senegal il loro togo i loro mali la
loro gambe alla loro costa d'avorio
luoghi che non sai ma dai quali pretendi
di farne una casa prigione senza porte
con finestre chiuse luoghi che non sai
da cosa e perché scappano da cosa
sognano di salvarsi
e mentre tu non sai loro sognano più
forte del male e invece a te chi ti
salverà giovane donna che non sei
razzista ma tra bisogni degli altri
uomini anziché coltivati tuoi che ti
salverà dai tuoi pregiudizi dalla tua
ignoranza dal tuo non saper sognare
per una volta prova a sognare più forte
di loro che hanno sognato più forte del
male fino ad arrivare qui da tempo loro
hanno fatto mari di mare in tempesta e
di uomini ben più spietati e di un
destino infinitamente più infame e di un
crimine centenario di una fame senza
fine della morte nascosta a ogni
tramonto un sogno credi davvero che li
fermerà il piccolo deserto del tuo cuore
per una volta prova a sognare più forte
di loro che hanno sognato più forte del
male
sino ad arrivare qui date prova a
sognare con loro e usa la tua rabbia per
colmare l'unica distanza che merita di
essere combattuta quella tra la realtà
di tutti i sogni di ciascuno
il sogno in bianco e nero testo di
sergio maglietta che è il cantante
reggae ska punk ed è un dialogo
immaginario tra due ragazzi cazzo vuole
quel biancuzzo di merda che fai ama gli
vai sotto alle cagli il culo per farti
fare una bella fotografia da mandare a
casa si badrone tuffare foto a me
[ __ ] a bligh sta esagerando quelle a
posto e tu rositi perché non ha i
documenti e non puoi farcela anche tu la
foto e poi rapper sono io tu non riesce
ad infilare due linee di fila neanche se
ti sparano
ma se prima di incontrarmi non sapeva
neanche cosa fosse una batteria
elettronica un loop ma guarda tu 2 rime
di fila io non sarei in grado di
scrivere due righe di fila di chi
ascolta queste piccolo uomo senti qua
pelle sotto pelle nera come la notte in
un mare agitato e il tuo scafo quasi
affonda di grida e paura e acqua e
freddo pelle che manca all appello del
giorno dopo come un topo caduto nella
trappola del desiderio ma il formaggio e
per loro pelle ribelle lucida pelle
digiuno è stanca lontana da casa pelle
frastornata da gli umanitari imbroglioni
vestiti di buone intenzioni di nobili
propositi e di parole doppie doppie come
le scorte di armi che usano di nascosto
quando l'occhio non vede e il loro cuore
bianco non sente con i guanti di
plastica pelle disarmata fine denti
pelle stracciato sui fili spinati alla
frontiera a brandelli giù fino alla cell
arti l'anima pelle pelle pelle che
bellissimo sai che è successo
già me li vedo i ragazzetti a chiederti
l'autografo e tu che gli sputi in faccia
davvero duro non c'è che dire con un
testo del genere fra i soldi con la pala
immagino che i biancorssi come dici tu
non aspettino altro che essere presa a
pesci in faccia da te ma tu guarda
questo ora è diventato pure un esperto
di show business ma vai va bè che c'è di
male ad essere protagonista una volta
tanto mettersi il vestito buono e
mostrare il sorriso che ancora siamo
capaci a farlo il sorriso intendo o il
sogno che c'è di sbagliato il mio sogno
non è degno di essere rappresentato
el'orgoglio il punto il mio orgoglio
quasi a essere orgoglioso e fiero anche
da perdente sono geloso della mia
tenerezza non è una cosa che si possa
xvi andrea re alla fine del paese al
mercato dei buoni sentimenti non è roba
per palati bianchi lo so capisco quello
che intendi dire sono d'accordo però me
questa cosa della fotografia del
ritratto come fossi uno importante piace
è un gioco
e poi a casa saranno felici di vedermi
così in tiro immagino basta che la tua
foto non vado a finire su qualche
opuscolo pubblicitario di porto ng in
cerca dell'otto per mille
no certamente finirà nelle mani di mia
madre che sarà fiera di suo figlio
filippo gatti cantautore le persone che
vengono da paesi lontani
specialmente quelle che non posseggono
grandi risorse spesso sono la cartina al
tornasole di una città quando sono
sorridenti e camminano per le strade a
testa alta o semplicemente distratti
significa che la città in cui stanno è
una città serena tollerante quando sono
cupi incappucciati è un po spaventosi
significa che sono in una città
aggressiva e respingente una città nella
quale le persone si parlano poco si
informano solo da piccoli schermi hanno
dimenticato la fatica del lavoro dei
propri nonni e vivono come parassiti
colpevoli gli abitanti di queste città
fanno paura a chi viene da lontano
li spingono a stare sulla difensiva o li
gettano nelle braccia di chi li sfrutta
quando visito una città la prima cosa
che guardo e se le persone che vengono
da lontano quelle con poche risorse
sorridono se solo coupé appena ho finito
il mio lavoro prende un caffè veloce e
riparto in fretta per parlare dove si
sta bene maldestro cantautore fin quando
il silenzio di molti sarà l'unica arma
per combattere le chiacchiere di pochi
questa terra non smetterà mai di
lacrimare fabrizio poggi bluesman i
sogni ti permettono di guardare il mondo
con gli occhi di un bambino
io non ho mai smesso di sognare martin
luther king diceva puoi uccidere il
sognatore ma non potrai mai uccidere il
suo sogno sognare e vivere ogni giorno
come se fosse l'ultimo
grazie
[Musica]